so i
immigrated to this country i'm i'm i was
born in the the soviet union
in russia and uh which one
which is an important question which you
were born in the soviet union right
yes i was born in the soviet union the
rest is details but i
grew up in moscow russia yeah but i came
to this
country and uh this country even back
there but
it's always symbolized to me a place of
opportunity
where everybody could build like uh
build the most incredible things
especially in the engineering side of
things
just invent and build and scale and have
a huge impact on the world
and that's been to me the that's my
version of the american ideal the
american dream
uh do you think the american dream
is still there uh do you think
what do you think of that notion in
itself like from an economics
perspective from a human perspective
is it still alive and how do you think
about it
the american dream the american dream is
mostly still there
if you look at which groups are the
highest earners
it is individuals from india and
individuals from iran
which is a fairly new development great
for them
not necessarily easy both you could call
persons of color
may have faced discrimination also on
the grounds of religion uh
yet they've done it that's amazing it
says great things about america
now if you look at native born americans
the story's trickier
people think energy intergenerational
mobility has declined a lot
recently but it has not for native born
americans
for about i think 40 years it's been
fairly constant
which is sort of good but compared to
much
earlier times it was much higher in the
past
i'm not sure we can replicate that
because look go to the beginning of the
20th century
very few americans finish high school
or even have much wealth there's not
much credentialism there aren't that
many credentials
so there's more upward mobility across
the generations than today
and it's a good thing that we had it i'm
not sure we should blame the modern
world
for not being able to reproduce that
but look the general issue of who gets
into harvard or cornell
is there an injustice should we fix that
is there too little opportunity for the
bottom say half of americans
absolutely it's a disgrace how this
country has evolved in that way
and in that sense the american dream is
clearly ailing
but it has had problems from the
beginning for blacks for women for many
other groups
i mean isn't that the whole challenge of
opportunity and freedom
is that it's hard and the difficulty of
how hard it is to move up in society
is unequal often and that's the
injustice of society but
the the whole point of that freedom is
that over time it becomes better and
better
you start to fix like uh fix
the the leaks the issues and it gives
that's it keeps progressing in that kind
of way
but ultimately there's always the
opportunity even if it's harder
there's the opportunity to create
something truly special to move up
to be to be president to be
a leader in whatever the industry that
you're passionate about to have it we
each have podcasts right
in english the value of joining that
american english
language network is much higher today
than it was 30 years ago mostly because
of the internet
so that makes immigration returns
themselves skewed
so going to the u.s canada or the uk
i think has become much more valuable in
relative terms than say go into france
which is still a pretty well-off very
nice country
if you had gone to france your chance of
having a globally known podcast
would be much smaller yeah this this is
the interesting thing uh
about how much intellectual influence
the united states has i don't know if
it's uh connected to what we're
discussing here the
the freedom and opportunity of the
american dream or
like does it make any sense to you that
we have so much
impact on the rest of the world in terms
of
ideas you know is it just simply because
the
english is the primary language of the
world or is there something fundamental
to the united states that
drives the development of ideas so it's
almost like
what's cool what's entertaining
what's uh you know like meme
culture the internet culture uh
the philosophers the intellectuals the
podcasts the
movies music all that stuff driving
culture
there's something above and beyond
language in the united states
it's a sense of entertainment really
mattering how to connect with your
audience
being direct and getting to the point uh
how humor is integrated
even with science yeah that is pretty
strongly represented here much more say
than on the european continent
britain has its own version of this
which it does very well
and not surprisingly they're hugely
influential in music comedy the
most of the other areas you mentioned
canada yes but their best
talent tends to come here but you could
say it's like a broader north american
thing and give them their fair share of
credit
what about science you you know there's
a sense
uh higher education is really strong
research is really strong in the united
states but it just
feels like culturally speaking when we
zoom out you know scientists aren't very
cool here
like most people wouldn't be able to
name basically a single scientist
maybe they would say like they would say
what like einstein and neil degrasse
tyson maybe
and neil degrasse tyson isn't exactly a
scientist he's a science communicator
so like there's not uh you know the same
kind of admiration
of uh science and innovators as there is
of like
athletes or actors actresses
musicians well you can become a
celebrity scientist if you want to
may or may not be best for science and
we have spock from star trek who is
still a
big deal but look at it this way which
country is most comfortable with
inegalitarian rewards for scientists
whether it's fame or money and i still
think it's here some of that's just the
tax rate
some of it is a lot of america is set up
for rich people to live really well
and again that's going to attract a lot
of top talent and you ask like
the two best vaccines i know the fights
are vaccine is
sort of from germany sort of from turkey
but it's nonetheless
being distributed through the united
states moderna
an armenian ethnic armenian immigrant
through lebanon first to canada then
down here to boston cambridge area
those are incredible vaccines and u.s
nailed it
yeah well that's that's more almost like
the
i don't know what you would call it
engineering the sort of scaling that's
what us is really good as
not just inventing of ideas but taking
an idea and actually building the thing
and scaling it and
being able to distribute it at scale
you